die krise extrem verunsichert so
zwischen dienen werde ich einfach wenig
auch einen abschätzen wie ein stich dass
jetzt tatsächlich wie neuerlich die
situation jetzt kopien ihrer familie
denn überhaupt wurde und wir sind leute
mit und stefan müller spricht von ebola
wie lebt man in sierra leone in einem
der ärmsten länder der welt mit der
seuchen wie gestaltet sich der alltag
davon handelt dieser film und davon wie
in der not neue zuneigung entsteht
[Musik]
es begann im letzten sommer in ganz
westafrika war die krankheit in
vormarsch nichts schien ebola
aufzuhalten weil sie in lausanne an ihm
versuch gestartet wird entschließe ich
mich daran teilzunehmen
die probanden sollen erträglichkeit und
allfällige nebenwirkungen des serums
testen
daraus soll rasch ein wirksamer
impfschutz gegen ebola entwickelt werden
120 versuchspersonen werden geimpft
eine davon ist stefan müller seine
motivation ist klar die haben einen sohn
wo 14 zimmer stand dass er ohne sie ist
vor vielen jahren wieder zurückgegangen
die hand aber natürlich aus familiärer
in der kontaktstelle falter vor allem
aber dessen sohn stefan müller lädt mich
ein ihn auf seiner alljährlichen reise
nach sierra leone zu begleiten
normalerweise kommt sein sohn aziz mit
dieses jahr ist nichts normal
es muss zu hause bleiben die impfungen
in lusern garantiert keine immunität
nur personen über 16 jahren können
teilnehmen nötig dass tägliches rotter
natürlich rein statistisch c ich meinte
bei den verhören wie sie vor der wir
noch unaxis das ist mal konnte richter
aber das heißt mitnichten dass das
problem behoben ist
der flug ist lang über zehn stunden zeit
um bei mir alle möglichen diffusen
ängste aufzubauen
stefan hat ganz konkrete probleme
die erste aktion war methode
mexikaner wird sie wieder groß auf
das
nicht ganz so einfach
wobei ich muss auch sagen was sie
gewusst und sie in der kurden
dann ist sie wieder vom signalisierte
auch geschrieben
von data gov dass sie also ängstlich
sind
in der abendsonne fliegen wir über den
grenzfluss nach sierra leone bei unserer
ankunft in freetown ein erstes anzeichen
der krise
allen passagieren wird noch vor der
passkontrolle die temperatur gemessen
berührungsfrei
und hier ist das empfangskomitee der
fahrer abo ist hier und abitur bangura
müller kurz
stefans ehefrau
dass ich dich umarmen
[Musik]
und freund ruhig karierte angebot zum
standort deutschland die das verfahren
so viele musiker und hat sich einfach
funkstille
morgens um fünf weckt mich gemurmel wie
ihr halbbruder orten das nachbarmädchen
santo und abu beten zusammen
auch stefan ist aufgewacht
drei babys darunter die max
am freitag bieten wir sonst in der
moschee aber in der moschee da drüben
ist der imam gestorben und seine ganze
familie
auch die bestatter die die leiche
waschen
alle sind gestorben
wir gehen nicht mehr in die moschee
wegen ebola man sollte sie nicht
berühren sagen sie auch stefan pflegt
sein morgenritual
auf der anderen straßenseite das blaue
zelt der ebola checkpoint wer ins dorf
will wird hier kontrolliert er muss die
hände mit chlorwasser spülen
die temperatur wird geprüft wer über
37,4 grad hat muss sich hinlegen und auf
die ambulanz warten musst du dir heute
schon jemanden anhalten
nein heute nicht aber vorher schon aber
heute morgen niemanden
auf der anderen straßenseite hilft die
armee bei der kontrolle der zwangsstopp
an der straße ist zugleich eine chance
für die kleinen händler
selbst der schmied hat seine erste
aufgestellt wir müssen geld wechseln und
fahren in die stadt
rund ein drittel der bevölkerung des
landes wohnt in freetown knapp über eine
million
überall wird dann ebuya erinnert
lautstark und überdeutlich
mit dem megafon werden die menschen
aufgefordert ihre kranken ins spital zu
bringen
übrigen you
200 dollar sollten reichen für unserem
aufenthalt 400 dollar entsprechen hier
einem jahresgehalt
beim weitergeben
[Musik]
auch die tagespresse kennt nur ein thema
dollar
heute gibt es eine gute nachricht der
impfstoff aus lausanne kommt nach afrika
das ist super und ich freue mich
natürlich wahnsinnig dass es jetzt so
schnell angegangen ist
[Musik]
ich lasse stephan seinen
alltagsgeschichten nachgehen und mache
mich auf die suche nach weiteren spuren
der solche blaue bänder die um ein
wohngebiet gespannt sind fallen mehr auf
ein polizist steht dabei wenn die leute
die bänder sehen wissen sie manchmal
nicht dass sie nicht durch dürfen dann
muss ich ihm erklären geht da nicht
durch hier ist klar an tele gebiet dann
halten sie an eine mitarbeiterin von mit
einer hilfsorganisation organisiert die
versorgung der ausgegrenzten bewohner
bevor sie aktiv werden kann muss
allerdings erste vorsitzende des
quartiers um erlaubnis gebeten werden
jeder der hier durchgeht muss sich bei
mir melden meint der chef wo ein ebola
fall aufgetreten ist wird ein ganzes
geviert für 21 tage gesperrt keiner darf
mir rein oder raus 123 personen wohnen
hier jede woche werden sie mit dem
notwendigsten versorgt das ebola opfer
hier eine frau hinterlässt den ehemann
und zwei töchter ein erstes mal werde
ich unmittelbar mit den auswirkungen der
krankheit konfrontiert
ich will mir gar nicht ausmalen wie es
am anfang der epidemie gewesen ist
es war grauenhaft und viele der menschen
starben im haus aus angst ins spital zu
gehen sie glaubten wenn sie ins spital
gingen würden sie getötet und dann haben
sie die leichen einfach in der nacht auf
die straße geworfen
sie haben nicht mal die ambulanz gerufen
weil sich davor fürchteten in die
quarantäne versetzt zu werden
aber ich muss sagen ich hatte auch angst
gehabt vor
ich hätte mich versteckt wir haben diese
idee dass sie mich sogar aufgeschnitten
hätten auch wenn ich kein ebola gehabt
hätte wenn ich sie sehe
verstecke ich mich diese ambulanz
mitarbeiter sie sind wieder todes in der
alma cool und gegen den wärst du dich
wenn du kannst ja wie und stefan sind
seit sechs jahren getrennt und seit
kurzem geschieden aber die zuneigung
scheint ihr wieder zu wachsen in letzter
zeit
er ist ein guter mann
ich begann ihm richtig zu leben also
schon in afrika zurück war
anstatt blödsinn zu machen pflege ich
halt hier meinen garten meine kleine
familie und ich engagiere mich in der
gemeinde aber ich weiß jetzt werde keine
neue liebe mehr finden wenn nicht mit
meinem mann
wenn ich mich hier mit einem einlasse
die wollen sich doch einfach in ein
gemachtes nest setzen die sagen jetzt
bin ich ein reicher mann
jetzt setze ich mich einfach mal hin
nicht so stephan
er kocht sogar für das ganze haus ein
fonds bei 33 grad
ich liebe raclette und fondue
[Gelächter]
die ganze patchwork familie nimmt am
festival teil
ob alles begeisterung teilen bleibe
dahingestellt
hier ist das zimmer von ja maria der
großmutter sie ist 97
um sie zu pflegen ist die ursprünglich
nach sierra leone zurückgekehrt
stefan zeigt wie der sohn aziz in der
schweiz afrikanische tänze vorführt
das ist der müller stefan hat noch ein
paar besorgungen zu machen was sie es
benötigt ein neues gewand für seine
tanzgruppe am vorabend bestellt ist es
heute schon zum abholen bereit
im radio läuft einmal mehr eine
belastung während wir zum großen markt
vorn
[Musik]
es ist 34 grad der schweiß fließt hier
wird etwas mulmig in dem gedränge
trotz unserer impfung sollten wir nicht
zufällige berührungen meiden
die fusion könnte auch mit und texas wo
natürlich bin ich von meiner absoluten
oder außenstelle über unser system ihnen
das land ein landtag ein falscher
handgriff im letzten moment und dann ist
die türe wahrscheinlichkeit sagen ich
habe oder deine chance
und was geschieht heute mit den kranken
ich fahre nach kontern und andere ende
der stadt im media spielt da kommt man
als erstes in die wäscherei hat das
virus mit seife abgetötet werden kann
eine zentrale stelle
dann die ebola patienten ob schon kein
medikament ebola heilen kann haben die
kranken heute bessere überlebenschancen
diese beiden konnten nach unserem film
gesund entlassen werden
zum glück werden auch immer weniger
angesteckt die kontrollen werden bereits
etwas gelockert das pflegepersonal nimmt
immer noch sehr ernst
anfänglich stammten 60 prozent der toten
aus dem gesundheitswesen insbesondere
hebammen waren äußerst gefährdet
laien sind hier nicht zugelassen also
muss meine kamera stellvertretend für
mich ins krankenzimmer
die symptome von ebola sind anfänglich
schwierig zu erkennen
in diesem zelt sind die verdachtsfälle
die kleine eisert vermutlich malaria von
außen werden die schwestern gecoacht und
kontrolliert in den schutzanzügen
herrscht eine temperatur von über 45
grad lange kann so niemand arbeiten
der einsatz ist beendet
die kleider der beiden schwestern werden
gründlich desinfiziert auch meine kamera
einer von desinfektions team hat ebola
überlebt als ich die ersten symptome
hatte rammte ich ins spital nach drei
tagen wurde ich positiv getestet dann
kam ich ins rot kreuz center wo ich nach
14 tagen ebola frei war
ich war zwar glücklich aber doch nicht
ganz so glücklich denn meine ganze
familie ist gestorben
ich bin der einzige überlebende
über 3000 tote hat es in sierra leone
gegeben aber man schaut wieder
vorsichtig vorwärts
stefan hat heute geburtstag und lädt uns
alle an die beach ein und die angst und
die trauer abgewaschen werden können
er sagt für mich selbst wenn ich ihn
stress sehe ich dass er sich kümmert das
beruhigt mich
und er lässt mich nicht einfach sitzen
du bist eine gute person stefan ich
wünsche dir das beste
[Musik]
7000 kilometer weiter nördlich in etwa
35 grad kälter besuche ich stefan müller
nochmals unsere quarantänezeit ist noch
nicht vorüber auch wir sollten 21 tage
warten bevor wir uns wieder ganz normal
bewegen dürfen
[Musik]
es bleibt zu hoffen dass unser ihm
versucht dazu beiträgt einen neuen ebola
ausbruch zu verhindern